Hello, hello, Serena.
Hey, I've been waiting on you.
What's going on?
I'm elated to ask you 73 random questions for your September collection debut...
...and congratulations on Wimbledon.
Thank you.
How are you feeling about life right now?
Life is pretty good.
And in life, how many matches do you think you've played?
Gosh, I don't know.
Somewhere, definitely over a thousand, I don't know.
Which of your competitors has helped improve your game the most?
Definitely Venus.
If you can master any other sport, what would it be?
I would do ballet.
Past or present, who would you love to play a match against?
Althea Gibson.
Past or present, who would be your dream doubles partner?
Honestly, I just can't get better than Venus.
Who is your tennis icon?
Monica Seles.
What is your strangest superstition?
I don't have superstitions.
What do you predict would happen if you hit someone with your serve?
Okay, we would have to immediately stop everything,...
...call 911 and rush them to the hospital.
That does not sound pleasant at all.
It's not.
It's not good.